Film Courage: Did you read a lot of horror books or
sci-fi growing? Chloe Carroll, Filmmaker/Writer/Actor: No I was terrible at
reading. I just watched films. I would
just go to Blockbuster and just get like
a pile of films and just watch them I I
was never a big reader and if I did I
would I would read short stories it's
actually a reason why I make like super
short films because I'm one of those
people who has a very short attention
span and it's really hard for me to sit
down for like two hours and watch a
movie without doing something else and
one of my idols is and the YouTube
channel Pony Smasher [David Sandberg and Lotta Losten] and I like love,
love, love them and I love that story and
they started out as a husband-and-wife
team and they were just and he does all
like BTS videos of how he made it and
it's literally like a two-minute short
with like I scare and I would just sit
and watch all of them like on a playlist
and I loved them and I could watch them
over and over again and I love thinking
about them I just think that's so
creative that's that's actually why I
started favorite because I was like I
love this stuff I am the audience for
this stuff and I know that I can be good
at making this stuff and so I wanted to
make like a no-pressure short film
channel originally with horror shorts
and you know not be like super worried
about big budgets like on feature films
just like no stress just I love
filmmaking let's make sure Horrors so
like yeah
when did you start favorite I started
Fear Crypt where did I start it I
started it two years after I meet so
2015 and it was because I made a short
film with my husband [Phillip Carroll] as like I would
like and we had his original logo on us
the guy would like a horror one I might
as well put a horror film company on
there like even if I don't go any
further with it and then it was from
there that I realized that he didn't
really want to pursue horror and he said
it but that doesn't that shouldn't ever
stop you just because I don't want to
like I'll teach you everything I know if
that's what you want to do like you have
to follow your dreams and I was like all
right I will and then and then I started
making more as like
might as well have a logo and then you
just start building something and like
I'm a big fun now I've just just do it
you know like you don't have to worry
about the future of something just do
what you want to do right now and if
it's something I'll become something and
I knew Pony Smasher did it too and that's
like I you know they barely had like a
crew and one thing I do right now is
with Fear Crypt is I collaborate with
filmmakers who are like in similar
positions as me where you know they want
to make film content they all have
YouTube channels but the main barrier is
always like financial problems like well
you know if I want to make a short film
you think I've got to raise like a few
thousand and do this and you I realized
that a lot of people are in the same
position as me whether like alright fine
you know I don't have a lot of money but
I want to you know make it short so we
split the budget now which is really
cool like I'll find like three or four
people who want to make like a micro
short or a short film and we all have
production companies you all have
YouTube channels we all want the content
but don't have like a load of money we
can just throw into it but if you split
the budget it's like not that much you
know and you all get the content you all
own the film you're all passionate about
something they're normally all big plays
on sets so like one person all also be a
DP that they want to produce so like
you're not worried about like hiring a
lot of crew because a lot of the
producers they're also big players on
set so that's what I've been doing
recently with my short films and it's
not been like a huge financial burden
because I'm doing it with people who are
in like-minded positions and ones who
also further their careers which is
awesome and there's a website too and
people can contact you if they want to
submit yeah my I have a website - it's
just Fear Crypt dot com and the YouTube
channel is YouTube and we're
just starting out so there's not like a
bunch of shots on there I think there's
maybe like seven now with
more come in like I'm filming one in
February ones in post-production so I
can't like shoot them out as quick as
like the horror channels that you know
shoot like two out a week but but
eventually hopefully when I have like a
hundred on there will be more things for
people to see and I can like put them
into subgenres cuz they're all different
right now but I'm also I really want to
do like the festival circuit no that's
that was not a goal that I had when I
first started but I would love to start
doing festival films that are a slightly
higher quality not so much like I've
made them for YouTube like there's a
little bit more money involved it's a
little bit better quality so I'm
starting that with my next shot film
which will be like slightly longer and
then eventually I'll go on the channel
and these are all individuals in the
Philadelphia area yeah it's really cool
and so if people didn't actually make
the film with you could they also have
it on your channel yeah I'm super open
to that I've had I've had a few people
inquire about that and it wasn't
something I originally thought but yeah
like it that once I have enough
followers and it's worthwhile for them
to put it on for exposure I would
totally do that I did that with a few of
my shots starting out before I had like
a YouTube channel and a home for them I
was like oh well this these horror
channels accept your shots and then they
give you like a lot of exposure and like
when you first start no you don't have
that many subscribers so unless someone
searches for it they're not gonna find
your work but it's slowly growing as I
put more content out there and the ones
that we submit to the big horror
channels like they they put them up and
they get like 12,000 views on the same
day which like if I put them on my own
channel like I won't get that so but now
hopefully when I build a channel and
they can put more content on there it
would be really cool I Pony Smasher you
did that's really cool yeah I saw I
really like your site too because you
have them you did like a few Q and A's
yeah I just started doing that because
No I know people are interested
especially on these like short startups
I guess where you are doing indie
filmmaking they want to know what you're
doing because they also want to do it
and they want to know like they they
want to know inside information sorry
yeah yeah so I thought it would be cool
like it's just a quick interview if
people want to watch the show films then
they're like oh I'm interested in
knowing who the DP was for that and what
they thought just like what you do when
you go to festivals and you do the Q&A s
but it's just an easy place if you watch
the content then you can find who was
involved in that I thought it would be
like a cool little thing have you ever
thought of starting your own horror
festival I have I thought about that a
lot actually but it's I think right now
I don't want to get distracted from
making the films which I feel like I
will because I'm one of those yes people
right now who did this and this and I
find it really hard to focus on like one
thing so I'm trying not to do too much
all at once and especially because I'm
in pre-pro with a short right now that
like I'm really passionate about and
it's gonna be slightly longer I guess
it's more like it's like my graduation
film from doing like short films when I
compare like how I'm starting compared
to like my husband here like went to
film school at school and he would make
these short films and then he'd make one
bigger thesis short film and then he was
ready to do a feature film
whereas cuz I'm just starting out and I
never went to film school I'm like oh my
goal these cool like low budget shorts
and then this is and then I'm ready to
make my like longer content you know I
feel like I've got enough experience now
to make like something a bit better and
then then I'll be ready for the future
so how much longer is this newer film
it's probably gonna be like 10 to 12
minutes so I'm not like really long but
I'm used to making like micro shots
which are like three to four pages like
three minutes short horror like ponies
my shadows rather like really quick you
know you you're at lunch and you want to
watch your horse
like one day yeah yeah yeah
you know it is
you